en los vídeos anteriores hemos estado
moviéndonos lentamente para nuestro
objetivo de averiguar el área de la
superficie de un toro verdad y lo hemos
hecho por la evaluación de un integral
de superficie es decir teníamos que
tomar la parametrización del toro tomar
su derivada parcial respecto de aceite y
eso fue lo que hicimos en el primer
vídeo después tomamos el producto cruz
de estos vectores y fue el segundo vídeo
ahora vamos a tomar la magnitud de este
producto cruz y entonces evaluar el
interior de esta integral integral doble
y que vamos a hacer algo que muy pocas
veces se hace en la carrera así que esto
es bastante emocionante este fue el
producto cruz que encontramos en el
vídeo anterior y vamos a sacar la
magnitud de esta cosa así que recordarán
que la magnitud de cualquier vector es
como un teorema de pitágoras verdad es
como la fórmula de la distancia pero
pero ahora en tres dimensiones así que
la magnitud esto esto es un recordatorio
n está esta magnitud es bueno déjenme
copiarlo la parcial de r
respecto de s cruz la parcial de r
respecto de t lo copió y lo pegó esto es
este vector muy bien estas estos dos
vectores son iguales ahora queremos
averiguar la magnitud de éste chango así
que lo copiamos y lo pegamos queremos
averiguar la magnitud o la norma de este
vector así que como ven hay un escalar
por ahí así que este sale en realidad
debería llevar un valor absoluto pero
bueno en realidad uno puede ver que éste
este valor es positivo ya que b es más
grande que a y luego la magnitud del
vector restante pues es la raíz cuadrada
de del de los cuadrados de cada
componente verdad de los cuadrados de
cada uno de los términos asociados a jk
así que déjenme escribir esta suma el
primero al cuadrado en realidad es a
cuadrada coseno cuadrado de ese consejo
cuadrado de s por el seno por el seno
cuadrado de t ese es el primer término
al cuadrado este que estamos subrayando
ahora le sumamos el segundo que estamos
subrayando en magenta al cuadrado que es
cuadrada coseno cuadrado de s
y por coseno cuadrado de t fue el
segundo ahora para el tercero voy a usar
otro color digamos este otro color y
esto elevado al cuadrado es cuadrada
seno cuadrado de s muy bien y todo esto
último vamos a obtener la raíz cuadrada
ok así que todo esto que estoy
subrayando es la magnitud de este vector
que subraya arriba muy bien y él ve
masako seno de ese es un escalar que
sale con valor absoluto pero como ya
dije esto en realidad es positivo así
que vamos a ir factor izando para poder
simplificar esta expresión este que
estoy subrayando lo podemos factorizar
de ambos y vamos a ver qué pasa voy a
escribir esta segunda parte como a
cuadrada coseno cuadrado de ese y esto
multiplicará por un lado a seno cuadrado
de t
más
bueno pongo el paréntesis me faltó más
el code
no no no no lo quiero dejar en magenta
ok más el coseno cuadrado de t muy bien
seno cuadrado más coseno cuadrado y
entonces
pues esto simplemente le sumamos después
a cuadrada seno cuadrado de s verdad y a
todo esto le sacamos la raíz cuadrada o
la potencia un medio verdad
entonces aquí podemos observar tenemos
seno cuadrado de temas coseno cuadrado
de t que es 1 es nuestra identidad
trigonométricas más básica verdad así
que esto lo podemos simplificar como
cuadrada coseno cuadrado de s más a
cuadrado más más más más es cuadrada
seno cuadrado de s y otra vez todo esto
hay que elevarlo a la un medio podemos
reconocer inmediatamente que podemos
factorizar una cuadrada verdad y nos
queda a cuadrada por coseno cuadrado de
s más no perdón me equivoqué más seno
cuadrado de s que otra vez todo lo
elevamos a la un medio y nos estamos
enfocando ahora escribir esto último de
forma más fácil y otra vez identificamos
la identidad trigonométricas que nos
dice que esto es igual a 1 así que esto
simplemente nos queda a cuadrada a la un
medio que va a ser igualada porque a es
positivo en realidad sería valor
absoluto de a pero a es positivo
así que todo esto se simplifica aa por
lo que este producto cruz
simplemente se simplificó a multiplicar
a por vez más a coseno de ese que es una
expresión muy sencillísimo así que
déjenme copiar
esta norma se simplifica así
déjenme ponerlo así se va a simplificar
por ve muy bien utilizando la propiedad
distributiva verdad esto es a por ve más
a cuadrada a cuadrada por el coseno de s
así que ya hemos llegado bastante lejos
y es agradable cuando teníamos algo
realmente espantoso y resulta en algo
bastante sencillo verdad es muy
emocionante y para repasar lo que hemos
hecho nuestra visión en los vídeos
anteriores era evaluar esa integral
verdad sobre la región de s
sobre la región que define al ala al
toro es decir que ese va de 0 a 2 p y te
va también de 0 a 2 pi así que queremos
integrar esta expresión en esta región
así que vamos a calcular la integral de
0 a 2 pi
respecto de ese que es el intervalo en
donde está definida es y la integral de
0 a 2 pi respecto de t que también es en
donde está evaluando t
y sólo hay que poner la expresión de
esta norma verdad que es en realidad lo
que acabamos de obtener hace unos
momentos que es ave más cuadrada coseno
de s muy bien ahora esto va a ser igual
a bueno sólo tomamos la integral
interior verdad esto es respecto de ese
y como veremos
déjenme ver así que copiamos esto que es
la integral de 0 a 2 pi respecto de t y
tenemos que poner una primitiva respecto
de s de lo que está adentro que esto va
a ser ave por s del primer sumando más a
cuadrada y cuál es la integral de cocina
de ese pues claro es seno de ese muy
bien y esto hay que evaluarlo de 0 a 2
pi
ahora si hacemos esta evaluación que es
lo que vamos a tener volvemos a poner
nuestra frontera de la integral que
tenemos la integral de 0 a 2 pi muy bien
y esto es respecto dt de en el primer
sumando cuando ponemos dos pi pues nos
queda dos por ave y cuando ponemos cero
pues simplemente se cancela verdad ahora
en el segundo sumando si tenemos a
cuadrada seno de dos pi en realidad seno
de dos pies cero verdad y luego le
restamos a cuadrada seno de cero que
también es cero muy bien entonces
realmente los demás términos son cero
así que ya estamos terminando esta
integral y estamos terminando la
integral y sólo hay que encontrar
encontrar una primitiva de dos pi ave
respecto de t y bueno 2p ave es una
constante para integrar respecto de t
así que esto será 2 pi a deporte y esto
habrá que evaluarlo de 0 a 2 pi cuando
vale 2 pi que ponemos 2 x 2 p
por ave es decir 2 pi al cuadrado por
ave y cuando vale 0 pues 0 por cualquier
cosa es 0 así que podemos omitir
escribirlo y ya hemos terminado este es
el área de la superficie del toro esto
es muy emocionante es una sorpresa
porque esto es igual a 4 y cuadrada por
ave que en realidad es una fórmula
bastante conveniente y muy sencilla ya
saben por ejemplo el área el área del
primer círculo el de radio a pues es 2 y
por a y el área del círculo de radio b
es 2 por b así que resultó ser el
producto de estas áreas en términos
generales se siente bien estamos tomando
sólo el producto de las áreas de los dos
círculos que definen al al toro así que
voy a copiar esta expresión déjenme
copiarlo por qué
porque fue muy gratificante así que
vamos a regresarlo al inicio de donde
empezamos el problema así que el área se
simplificó a esta expresión es muy
emocionante y ahora sabemos que si
tenemos un toro donde el radio de la
sección transversal es ah y el radio
desde el centro hasta hasta la mitad de
las secciones transversales es b
entonces el área de la superficie de ese
toro va a ser 4 pi cuadrada por a por b
y pienso que es un resultado muy
satisfactorio estoy muy contento